(upbeat holiday music)
- I live for that day.
For that Christmas week.
That's my everything.
- I got something for you.
- Oh.
- And it may be you put
this under the tree.
♪ Feliz Navidad ♪
(bell dings)
- [Burt] Oh bingo!
(audience applauds)
♪ Feliz Navidad ♪
(upbeat holiday music)
- So you are probably wondering
(laughs) why I'm sitting in a chair.
'Cause usually I start standing.
Well, this is our first holiday show.
Woo! (laughs)
(audience applauds)
And I was really excited about it.
And we are running late,
and I don't like to be late.
And so I was running.
And my heel, which was
a bad decision because
apparently I turned a corner,
and possibly did something
to my ACLs. (laughs)
(laughter)
It's so fun.
So, 2020.
Just the gift that keeps on giving.
It's a really good year.
(audience applauds)
So, I can't,
I have to elevate,
I don't wanna like not do the show.
It's beautiful here.
You are here.
I'm here.
Like, so I'm just gonna
sit in this chair (laughs)
with my egg,
my egg,
with my leg elevated.
I've now had a patch,
'cause I had the eye situation.
And then now I have a knee situation so,
you know what?
There is an award I won,
Mrs Meek if you are out
there, from the eighth grade,
I won an award in my eighth grade.
Nobody knows this.
They don't even know
I'm about to say this.
But I just thought of it.
I won Crisis of the Day Kelly award.
(laughter)
I did.
They knew in the eighth grade,
just, I don't know why it happens,
but stuff happens.
And I well, I was running
in heels and turned a corner
like I'm some kind of athletic
person that can do that,
and it didn't go well.
Anyway.
So, no to self people.
Stay healthy.
Don't run in your heels,
or turn corners,
or be in a hurry.
'Cause then you are gonna end up
looking like a fool on television.
So (laughs) here we go.
(upbeat holiday music)
Are you as big of a nerd
about Christmas as I am?
- Yeah.
- I'm like Chevy Chase level decorating.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my house is fully decorated.
Look.
That's our life.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Meghan] Those are our real pajamas.
- I get the same thing.
We do the same thing.
- We should do it together. (laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
We should have like a war of like,
who came up with the
funniest Christmas card.
- [Meghan] Okay, okay.
- Why did I make it a competition?
- [Meghan] It's on. (laughs)
- It's so weird.
- I live for that day.
For those,
that Christmas week.
That's my everything.
- Oh, that's so great.
So what was your favorite
Christmas song as a kid?
'Cause there's so many.
- There are so many.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I really loved Michael
Buble's White Christmas.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- It was good.
I love all your Christmas stuff.
We did a Christmas show together.
- [Kelly] We did.
- I totally forgot that
until this moment right now. (laughs)
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
until you said that,
I literally went back and
my brain went "Mm-hmm, yep."
(laughs) (indistinct)
And I'm not pregnant.
- (laughs) We did a
Christmas show together.
In like Nashville?
- Yep.
That was when people could go to shows.
- Yes, yes it was. (laughs)
- Yeah, and we were in
the arena, Bridgestone.
That was sad that we can't do that now.
That's so right.
I love you.
So you had some help you said
putting this record together, right?
- Yes I did.
- Your whole family pitched in.
- And some big song writers.
- Was it everyone
in the picture? (chuckles)
- Big producers.
Yes.
It was my older brother
and my younger brother,
and my husband,
and my family was my background singers.
'Cause those are the only human
beings I saw in that time.
And we were all like very
clean, very protective.
My dad's on the older side of things,
and I was pregnant.
So none,
my brothers like never
left the house for me.
And like getting groceries
is very hard, (chuckles)
but we did it very safely.
And my husband would dress up and shower.
So, yeah.
- Well, speaking of your hubby,
what's up guys!
How y'all doing?
(audience applauds)
- This is great.
What's up Kelly Clarkson!
- (laughs) I love you.
- [Meghan] Kelly Clarkson!
(laughter)
- I love that y'all are in
front of a Christmas tree.
So all right guys.
First, congrats on being
a new dad and uncle.
That's exciting.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, they are so sweet.
- I'm a funcle.
- [Meghan] He is a funcle.
- A funcle? (laughs)
I was like, wait, what?
You can't say that on daytime. (laughs)
So how did you break the news to everyone?
How did y'all?
- Oh, well they saw me as
soon as I peed on the stick.
(laughs)
I ran out and like the
videotape one was just shaking.
It was like, "I did it!"
'Cause the whole house knew.
I didn't want it to be that big
of a surprise for the house.
I was like, just so y'all know,
we are doing science over here.
So heads up.
Don't be surprised when
I come out with a stick.
So when I did that, they were like,
"What is it?
"A pregnancy test?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
- Oh my gosh.
I love it.
- That's how we did that.
- I mean, but that's really fun though.
Everybody's quarantine sucked.
That would have been
awesome in a fun house.
You are so half glass full, I love you.
(upbeat holiday music)
- Nice to meet you.
Yes, yes.
- Good to meet you ladies.
First, I gotta start off,
a big fan of both of you.
- Thank you.
- Big fan of both of you.
- [Kelly] Even if you
are lying, I love it.
- No, I am definitely not lying.
I am definitely not lying.
- Well, what's up with you.
How are you?
How are things? (laughs)
(laughter)
- I am doing fantastic.
(laughs) I am doing fantastic.
This might be a thing that works. (laughs)
- Can I just touch you
the whole time? (laughs)
Just keep going. (laughs)
Tell us about the game Burt.
Just tell us.
- It's super simple. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I'm gonna ask you guys
a series of questions
about Christmas.
If you know the answer,
use these (chuckles)
ridiculously long arms
to smash the button on the podium.
Kelly you are gonna be playing
for the right side of the audience,
and Gwen, you are playing for
the left side of the audience.
Get it right, and you get a point.
Get it wrong,
and you have to chug one of
your holiday themed cocktails
on your tray.
- Oh, see this might be the first time
I try and lose. (laughs)
(laughter)
- (laughs) Winner gets a cool prize
for her side of the audience.
And I just want you guys to know
this is one of the coolest prize
this show has ever given away ever.
- Boom.
- And if Gwen wins,
she also gets her photo melted
on the Blake Shelton wall of champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- It's rude.
It's a rude gift he gave her.
- Right next to Billy Gardell.
- Exactly.
Urgh, there are so many up there.
- You are parting with a lot.
(laughs)
Now, (laughs)
Because Blake is about to
become Mr. Gwen Stefani,
Ellie with that,
yeah, or I'm going either.
- Yeah, whatever he
wants to do, it's 2020.
- Yeah, whatever he wants to choose to be.
Yeah.
Kelly gets to remove
Blake's photo from the wall.
(laughter)
Ladies, are you ready?
- I am so ready.
- All right, here we go.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(upbeat music)
- According to legend,
what holiday goodies are
shaped as a shepherd staff
to remind children--
- Oh oh oh!
- [Burt] Of the shepherds
who visited baby Jesus?
(buzzer clinks)
- [Burt] Gwen.
- Candy Canes!
(bell dings)
- Candy Canes is our winner.
- I didn't know that.
I didn't know that.
- Kelly, Kelly, you gotta chug.
- I didn't know.
Damn straight.
- Sure you didn't know that?
- Which one?
I didn't know that.
- Can I tell you, I
didn't know that either.
I thought it was just--
- Kelly, Kelly come on.
You are letting me win.
- He didn't know it.
No I didn't know that.
- I swear to God.
When I read the thing, I swear to God
I thought it was just the
stuff they put on trees.
- Do you know what I was gonna go with?
I was gonna go with the cinnamon stick
because it looks like, you
know, it looks like that.
I didn't know.
I'm gonna go for Mulled Wine.
- Mulled Wine.
Because I'm sophisticated.
- Prayer works you guys.
I prayed before I came out.
(laughter)
- [Burt] (laughs) By the way, I did too.
- Oh that's really good.
- (laughs) You are my new best friend.
- My staff can make a really good drink.
- [Gwen] Is it good for real?
(laughter)
- Okay.
Next question.
- [Kelly] I got this one.
- What vegetable is a Christmas item
that serves both as a reindeer
food and as a snowman's nose?
(buzzer beeps)
Kelly.
- Carrots.
- Carrot's a winner.
One point for Kelly.
Gwen, time to chug.
(audience applauds)
- Which one are you gonna choose Stefani?
- I was told backstage,
this one.
- That's a good one.
That's a good one.
- Well, nobody told me
a great one. What?
- What's that one called?
- Puerto Rican Coquito?
- Yes.
- A Coquito.
- Yes, thank you.
- Coquito.
- Coco hito.
Like a mohito but with coco.
- You know what?
Let me just try it with you.
(laughter)
- Might as well try it.
- Oh my God.
That is thick like--
- Oh my gosh.
- Wow, that is--
- I'm kind of bummed out
at whoever produced
this segment right now.
I am sitting here dry.
- (laughs) You are.
This is rude.
The Kelly Clarkson Show sucks for Burt.
- I would share but, COVID.
- That's really good.
- (laughs) Share but COVID.
That's gonna be my new line.
(laughter)
Sorry guys, this whole bottle
of wine gives me COVID.
(laughter)
All right ladies,
last question with five points.
- Oh she is feeling it.
She got competitive.
I like this.
- I am.
- You are both gonna know this.
So really get ready.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- How do you say Merry
Christmas in Spanish?
(buzzer beeps)
That's Gwen, that's Gwen.
- What!
- Gwen.
♪ Feliz Navidad ♪
(bell dings)
- [Burt] Oh, Bingo!
♪ Feliz Navidad ♪
(audience applauds)
- Gwen, you are the
winner and I will place--
- [Kelly] Did I hit that first?
- Where is the left side?
- I hit that first.
I would like a playback,
but its fine.
(laughter)
- I can't.
This is literally monumental for me.
- I am not taking it from you.
Get on that wall with your fiance.
- All right, here we go.
Right next to Billy Gardell.
- All right, whatever.
- I can't believe Billy Gardell
is next to Natalie Portman.
- Yes, wow.
See like, look how much
cooler you are than Blake.
How did that happen?
(Gwen laughs)
- [Burt] Boom.
- Look at that photo. (laughs)
(upbeat holiday music)
Is your house holiday ready?
Are you and your wife,
are y'all really into
decorating or anything?
- Oh yes, oh yes.
Now this year is
especially exciting because
every year Catherine and I,
we argue over,
first of all, what kind
of lights go on the tree.
She likes those little, little simple,
simple, they are beautiful.
They are beautiful for God's
sakes, wherever she is.
(laughs)
But I like those big bulb,
the colored ones, the
green, blue, orange, red,
you know those guys.
And so this year it's my
turn for the big lights.
But as well, my wife
does not care for tinsel.
And when I was a kid,
we always had tinsel.
It was probably lead when I was a kid.
It was probably not good tinsel to have,
but I loved that tinsel.
So this year I get the
big lights and the tinsel.
So we are ready to go.
- Oh my gosh.
Here is my thing.
I'm with your wife, if
she doesn't like tinsel.
Tinsel is messy.
- (chuckles) That's exactly why.
(laughter)
- Okay, yeah.
Yeah.
Probably 'cause your wife
is the one picking it up.
I'm just saying, like, (laughs)
- That's exactly right.
- (laughs) Like, that is,
that will make a good day
go bad real quick, Kyle.
(laughs)
No, but that's okay.
It's your year, you do you.
So what's the most memorable
Christmas gift you ever got?
- Oh, I have had a lot
of great Christmases.
I got a BB gun one year.
And you know, that's a passage of right.
A young man gets his first,
his first rifle.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- And my parents went on a vacation.
They went on a trip somewhere.
It was my sister who is seven
years old and I at the house.
And he made it very explicit,
"Do not touch that BB gun."
But of course I knew where he hid it.
He put everything up on
the top of his closet.
You know, Christmas presents.
They didn't notice it,
but all of them had little
tears in all the corners,
'cause I'd been up there like a squirrel
trying to figure it out.
(gasps)
But I took that BB gun out of there
and my sister said, "What are you doing?"
I said, "I'm gonna take this outside,
"and I'm gonna shoot it."
And she goes, "Well, don't aim that."
I said, "It's not loaded Kelsey."
And she goes, "Well, just be careful."
I said, "It's not loaded,
don't worry about it."
Now we had this very
beautiful picture window,
a double pane picture window in Illinois.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I said, "It's not loaded."
And so I aimed it and
I pulled the trigger.
Well, I'll tell you what.
Right in the middle of
that giant picture window
was a beautiful little bullet hole.
You know, just perfect.
I started crying.
I cried and cried.
It was the most terrifying
thing in my life.
But so, just like Ralphie.
(laughter)
- Yeah, just like Ralphie.
I know, I know.
Don't go sticking your tongue on a pole.
(upbeat holiday music)
(audience applauds)
All right.
So what's your favorite
thing about New York
at Christmas time?
- It really is the vibe.
And it's just a magical place.
I mean, New York city just has that,
you know, they just go big.
I mean, it's like,
I think the window
shopping is pretty awesome.
It doesn't get old for
me, whether it be Macy's,
or you know, FAO, or Saks Fifth Avenue.
Just going by the windows,
it's all done up beautifully.
And it's a scene,
and they spent hours and probably years
working on those window displays.
They are just gorgeous for
everybody and it's free.
- Yeah, and they make you,
yeah, they make you feel so happy.
I'm with you.
And what was like your best
gift that you still remember?
- Oh, best gift definitely,
I got an electric guitar.
I'll never forget it.
I was probably 12, 13, and I got,
it was just awesome looking.
It was a fake Fender Strat.
It was red and white.
The name of the company was Phantom.
But it was so cool and was so,
I remember being so heavy.
I was like, I didn't know
guitars were that heavy.
And I wasn't even that good,
but I felt like a rock star holding it.
It was so awesome.
I love it.
I love you Santa.
(laughter)
And I also,
my worst gift ever was,
one year,
I don't know why,
my Santa Claus got me a DVD
of the movie, "Big Chill."
- "Big Chill"?
- Again, I'm like 13 years old.
So this is a movie about, you
know, midlife crisis. (laughs)
(laughter)
I don't know why I'm on the list,
but I remember going, "Okay."
(laughter)
"Big Chill."
About people trying to have a
baby and stuff like (chuckles)
yeah, okay.
But I guess Santa thought the
soundtrack was good (chuckles)
that I would like it.
I love it now.
Now that I'm in my forties. (chuckles)
But when you are a kid--
- Oh my God.
That's amazing.
- No, that was not one of my best gifts.
- That's a weird gift
that they definitely
weren't thinking of you
when they got it. (laughs)
(laughter)
They were like, "We forgot."
- I think Santa was thinking of Santa.
- "We forgot to get, so we just
pulled something." (laughs)
(upbeat holiday music)
Give it up for the lovely
Miss Carrie Underwood.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat rock music)
- Hi.
- (laughs) Hi.
How are you?
- How are you?
- I am so good.
I love your red.
I love it, is it satin?
That's nice.
And velvet?
Or what is that?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly[ That's nice.
- It's like a smoking jacket, I guess.
That's what you call that?
- [Kelly] I like it.
It's very distinguished.
I like it.
- Yes.
- It is such a great time
for you to be releasing this record.
Everybody needs this kind of hope.
Everybody needs this, just cheerfulness.
This reminder that humanity
is not going down in flames. (laughs)
(laughter)
And everything isn't going so poorly.
Did you feel like inspired
to do the Christmas record
right now because of that?
- No.
I mean, that was kind of after the fact.
Like, we had started working
on this Christmas album,
and it was something
I've always wanted to do.
I knew it was inevitable.
If you have, you know,
a career that lasts any timespan at all,
you are gonna make a Christmas album.
You just have to.
And I've always wanted to.
So we kind of got the wheels in motion
at the end of last year.
And then 2020 just dumped
itself in our laps. (laughs)
And it was just trying to figure out
how to keep moving
forward and make it happen
despite 2020.
- Yeah, definitely, definitely.
It was a perfect time to release that.
I'm really happy you are doing it.
And we just saw,
I don't know if you've noticed, we saw,
'cause you are remote,
but we saw real life
Griswold family house.
Were you a fan of "National
Lampoon's Christmas Vacation"?
Or was there another Christmas movie
that always did it for you,
that you have to watch every year?
- I mean, I think everybody is
a fan of "Christmas Vacation"
right?
- It's so great.
- It's a classic.
I also consider "Die
Hard" a Christmas movie.
- Oh my gosh!
I love that "Die Hard."
First of all, I love all the Die Hards.
But I love that it's at
Christmas time, the party.
It counts.
- It is.
It's a Christmas movie.
- That is a Christmas classic.
I will go with that.
Well, I have to ask you about this photo.
So here, I'm gonna put it up for you.
This is awesome. (laughs)
(laughter)
So, here is the thing I
love about this picture.
My kids naturally, they
gravitate towards Ursula,
not Little Mermaid.
They gravitate towards
Gaston, not The Beast.
I don't know what's wrong with them.
But does yours gravitate
towards the Grinch
(chuckles) instead of Santa?
- He just loves kind of the
creepy, like aspect of things.
So he would like,
like "Nightmare before Christmas"
which is, you know, a Christmas movie.
But he likes like the creepyness of it.
I mean, he loves Santa.
He has the sweetest heart.
I don't know.
He is my child.
I like scary movies and
the creepy stuff too.
I swear I have not imposed
any of my stuff onto him.
This is just what he likes going for us.
So he loves The Grinch.
- It's so funny.
'Cause I'm opposite.
Like, I don't like anything scary,
and my kids love it.
Like, I'm the one sitting
on the couch going,
"Why can't we just like, watch
like something really happy?
"Like, (chuckles) why does
everything have to scare me?"
Speaking of children though,
Isaiah,
so, you sang a duet
with him on the record.
And I saw on the special as well,
there is video footage of him as well.
So, was he excited to hear
himself on the record?
- He was.
I had no idea what was gonna happen.
You know, he's never been in
that kind of situation before.
I don't think he's even been
like in the studio with me
ever before.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I don't know if he
knows what I do at all,
but I just thought,
I could hear his voice on it in my head
when I was singing it in the studio.
And I just thought I'd ask him
and see if he might want to.
And he did such a great job.
And listening back,
like, I feel like he is
just so proud of himself.
And he went to school,
and he is like, "Hey, my song's out.
"You wanna hear my song?"
- [Kelly] My song's out. (laughs)
- [Carrie] And they were like
listening to it in his class.
- I think it's adorable.
And it's cool I think
that, when we are singers,
that our kids take some kind
of interest in what we do.
That's kind of cool.
(upbeat holiday music)